das sind alles für würstchen ist so
leckere geräucherte leute was habe ich
da gerade im gehört was habe ich da
gerade eben gehört heute geht er weg
aber jetzt bin ich wieder am start für
euch und ich habe für euch ein video aus
den tiefen des internets ausgegraben
dass wir uns heute zusammen anschauen
werden und dass uns dazu bringen wird
endgültig an der menschheit zu zweifeln
ich werde gar nicht lange drum leute ist
ein video von dem kanal family stories
und in diesem video tritt auf unsere
geliebte sahne süchtige daniel falls ihm
einen kanal schon bisschen länger
verfolgt habt ihr von der auch schon
raus gehört und ja ich noch nicht ganz
verstanden was wir jetzt in diesem video
vor hat aber ich glaube es hat irgendwas
damit zu tun dass sie mit würstchen
zaubern will
sollte das ist dann hier die es bisher
auf dem kanal dadurch in den schatten
getreten dass sie wie gesagt süchtig
nach sahne ist und wie dafür bekannt ist
scheinbar in deutschland ich weiß auch
nicht warum das sie halten sich so ganze
sahne sprühdose nimmt und sich die dann
einfach zwischendurch mal so reinigt
aber leute das ist nicht alles diese
frau ist nicht nur seine süchtig sondern
sie denkt wirklich auch noch das kann
scheint also dem wirklich dass sie
zaubern kann
schauen wir mal wie sie es macht da ich
bin dann in den laden rein hat diesen
einig bilder gesehen und diese passte
war dachte ich so gut zum einstieg kann
man ja mal probieren
kannst du mal austesten ob es wirklich
klappt was ich vorhabe okay okay das
muss ich jetzt mal gemerkt wie das video
heißt schutz wurst gefällig also sie
will quasi mit hilfe von einem hot dog
jetzt ein schutz zauber machen die
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend ich habe die auch noch
ausgependelt hat eine kopfwäsche wirst
du dann die besten sind vielleicht sechs
leute da haben wir es wieder also dass
wieder ein perfektes beispiel dafür wie
ja einfach so von allen guten geistern
verlassen
diese frau ist die geht jetzt allen
ernstes mit einer wünschelrute oder was
auch immer das ist was sie da in der
hand hält deswegen sind so ein holzgriff
mit somit hals starb lagen der umbau mit
in den supermarkt um herauszufinden
welche bockwurst bockwurst am besten
dafür geeignet ist um den schutz zauber
an dieser stelle einzusetzen
falls ihr euch jetzt in diesem moment
denkt dass wir menschen es eigentlich
nicht verdient haben auf dieser erde zu
existieren dann stimme ich zu
heute ich gucke und diese abrutschen auf
eurosport sendet schließlich habe ich
die wissen auch getestet das denn für'n
quatsch wenn sie bestimmt vorne an der
theke warten bis ich ihnen die brötchen
eingepackt habe die frau
ok also unser supermarkt einkauft geht
weiter wir haben jetzt schon die
richtigen würstchen gefunden die wir
natürlich unbedingt brauchen um in
schutz zauber überhaupt erst an zu
wirken um uns überhaupt erst mal in
unserem leben schützen zu können
brauchen wir natürlich was versicherung
vorsichtiges verhalten nein wir brauchen
schutz zauber mit bockwürsten und
dadurch natürlich die richtigen
ätherischen brötchen nicht fehlen
ich hab das zauber wie wirds gesehen ich
meine das ist ja eigentlich ein zeichen
da wussten wohl die guten geister dass
ich in diesen laden gehen und einkaufen
wir haben dann wohl die guten geister
wer auch immer das ist geahnt dass da
nie hier in den laden geht weil sie sich
mit einem bockwurst zauber schützen
möchte und haben dann erst mal gewürze
dahin gezaubert bald achtung sehen wir
hier steht ja drauf magic spies es steht
ja magic spies drauf dann wird man da
wohl die wohl zaubern können oder den
einkaufswagen einfach nicht raus
genommen
ich hab' gedacht 'was ist ein idealer
verkaufswagen darum dachte ich so gut
genutzt zudem für deine esoterik otto
okay jetzt würdet ihr wahrscheinlich
sagen als normalsterbliche oder ich
würde das auch sagen hey was soll das
soll der der wagen ist eigentum des
supermarkt sind kannst du nicht einfach
mitnehmen kannst dich ja auch für dein
bratwurst hot dog stand da benutzen
falsch oder er anders gesagt wollt ihr
allen ernstes einer derart mächtigen
zauberin wie danni im weg stehen ich
habe mich umgeschaut wie muss ich ja
werbung machen weil ich so einen großen
zettel hatte habe ich gedacht so gut da
hängen so viel herum
also hat jetzt unsere große zauberin
dani nachdem sie im supermarkt
erfolgreich die leute belästigt hat und
sich im magic spies geholt hat jetzt den
supermarkt verlassen und reist jetzt
hier draußen erst mal die werbeschilder
vom supermarkt runter um die dann
umzudrehen und werbung für ihre schutz
bratwürste zu machen darauf muss man
erst mal kommen
[Musik]
okay leute jetzt wirklich bitte ganz
genau hinschauen da sehen wir jetzt
schon den prozess im vollen gange
der zauber grill ist aktiviert die
richtigen magischen würstchen wurden
ausgewählt und jetzt werden die
magischen würstchen auf den grill party
ok achtet dabei auch wie konzentriert
das gesicht zum beispiel zu sehen
so sieht eine frau aus die einen plan
hat mit dem was habe ich da gar dem
gehört was habe ich da gerade eben
gehört okay wir müssen erst mal bevor
wir auch das eigentlich was ich gerade
in sagen wir müssen uns das ganze mal
den kopf gehen lassen okay
stellt euch vor diese frau läuft vor
euch über so ein parkplatz von so einem
supermarkt spricht er die an
nein wenn ihr vernünftig gewesen seid
dann nehmt ihr eure beine in die hand
und rennt weg und alle spielt das sind
selbst wenn ihr wie diese junge dame
hier dann doch ins gespräch mit dieser
frau kommen solltet und ihr dann die
frage was verkaufst du da und sie sagt
sie verkauft schutz würstchen so heilige
egal ich glaube ich würde einfach ich
will aber vor verwirrung und vor muss
losigkeit einfach aufhört zu existieren
in diesem moment
denn mal probieren sind heute für 499 im
angebot es ist ja auch nicht irgendein
wirst du sein premium würstchen gewesen
hat schließlich auch schutz und heilige
kräuter abgekriegt das finde ich nämlich
das finde ich nämlich tatsächlich auch
und da muss ich sagen will ich wieder
auf dann nicht seite also wenn man schon
sich die mühe macht unheilige würstchen
fertigt ja ja die haben auch
schutzabkommen und heilige kräutern darf
man dem moment nicht vergessen sind
alles kostenfaktoren ihr habt keine idee
was so heilige kräuter goss auf jeden
fall wenn man dann diese leistung bietet
okay man ist schon so nett als begabte
malerin daniel ok und bietet der
einfachen deutsche bevölkerung fakten
schutz anschutz würstchen magische dann
kann man auch mal 450 für eine wurst
nehmen die komplett verbrannt ist schon
komisch aus die gc noch gut ist sie ist
die komplette lebensmüde hat die gerade
eine heilige schutz wurst zurückgewiesen
[Musik]
nicht unbedingt
die klügste entscheidung also leute ich
muss jetzt wo ich das hier gerade sehe
noch mal in aller ernsthaftigkeit betont
falls eure eltern euch das auch nicht
mitgeteilt haben wenn euch in eurem
leben irgendwann mal eine heilige schutz
wurst angebot wird dann lehnt die nicht
ab doch nicht lebensmüde also ab heute
versuchen so viele leute habe ich kein
verständnis ganz ehrlich also man kann
nicht an einen heiligen schutz
wurststand gehen und dann erwarten dass
die wurst gut schmeckt das ist nicht der
sinn der sache
das ist kein fucking was hast du gedacht
was das ist normale haut doch mit mit
senf normale hot dog mit senf im
brötchen solchen ist doch toll aber ich
weiß viele leute die haben da wirklich
vorstellung meine würstchen hatten ja
auch funktionen ich fand sie hatten
schließlich schutz
okay leute jetzt ist immer kurz
anschauen also wir sehen jetzt hier
gerade mal die die heiligen würstchen
abwehr einer von euch lasst euch sagen
es sind heilige würstchen mit heiligen
kräutern und schutz keine diskussion
aber wenn wir jetzt hier gerade so sehen
dann bin ich tatsächlich so der meinung
gekommen in 100 das ist wirklich wichtig
ist auch dass die schutz haben weil so
geisteskrank verbrannt wie die sind
kriegt man wirklich krebs wenn der
schutz nicht sieht also ich störe mich
bisschen so daran dass das niemals in
echt zu passieren würde niemals also
erstmal würden sich leute einfach zu
einer frau hingehen die schon so nicht
ganz vertrauenserweckende aussieht und
ihm zusätzlich dazu noch in einem
einkaufswagen grillt okay nicht
vergessen die gerät in einem
einkaufswagen und dann geht man dahin
selbst wenn man so dumm ist wie er
erhört und man so hingehen und sagen hey
was das cool ist und dann sagt die einem
dicker sn pack in schutz würstchen
esoterische schutz würstchen
dann lauft doch einfach weg fühlst du
nicht einfach so ein den kaufen
wie sind sie darauf gekommen ich hatte
so ein verkehrsunfall und ich war nicht
richtig angeschnallt ich bin so auf der
autoscheibe vorne so rausgeschossen
dann hatten wir gegen so eine wand
geklatscht seitdem mache ich das halt so
ich habe mir gesicht gegeben gekontert
und einfach rasiert also jetzt mal ganz
ernst die wurst die ist verbrannt ich
gehe zum ordnungsamt ich habe eine idee
sich gemerkt das denken sich wieder ist
aber ich habe ein gesicht mit 10.000
fressen dann nehme ich alles so super
leute aber er sollte das was so weit von
unseren heutigen ausflug in die abgründe
von deutschland jetzt geht noch eine
bitte an euch raus wenn auch ihr ein
gesicht mit 10.000 fressen habt dann
schreibt man die kommentare wofür er
eine schutzlose gebrauchen könnte ist
und tschechien für euch persönlich
vorgeschlagen das video auf das was von
mir bleibt geschützt und achtet auf eure
heiligenkreuz